you
when we last met princess Britannia our
lady had imbibed a bit too much tavern
brandy and today's sunrise she had
lightened some less than noble choices
no-no-no
good morning my precious pedal [ __ ] I
hope this doesn't offend your royal
palate but I made you claps yeah I have
a stomach thing so this will go straight
through me
I brought room remedies for that thanks
a lot
sit awesome and while I have you here
can I go over some jokes with you for my
routine let's eat
mmm not ye not up here that
yep that's the drawbridge
I better get rolling they don't wait for
me call for me yeah yeah last night was
ravishing
yeah let's sword yeah beat that Todd
full circle you're Larry
that's a sure princess betánia okay yeah
to my beautiful blushing princess I
cannot wait to dig your mode again
remember from last night we made love
last night I'm talking about we made
love last night okay thank you
there's more I absolutely do not want to
hear it ah
Britannia come time for the performance
big event in public lots of witnesses
yes Jessica requests our royal presents
oh yes Daddy I don't wanna
and then I stated that's no sword that's
no penis that's my time thank you so
much try the boar dip your winch hmm
that's not following that he's good
incredible tight tight please don't
touch me Oh No
a lot please I call this the muse sits
before me the muse sits but I still
smell the sweat on your neck through my
nostrils as they juggle their desires
Thank You Jessica
that wonderful experimental performance
yes thank you anyway
how's your say oh okay Judy's a Slater
how about a little now and a little
later
stop it could few insig no I'm sorry
last night was in my bed I shouldn't
have slept with you you didn't want to
prick spindles with me no less it was
weird I saw my ex got drunk found a shoe
we'll talk a poly won't talk about this
delightful hmm a sad gesture how
original
Jan you broke my heart
sounds like someone might want to take
revenge on such a Dark Soul yeah yeah
maybe tell me